Salut à tous, aujourd'hui on est samedi. C'est le jour du Master Class,
le Master Class spécial règles de grammaire.
Ne partez pas, je rigole, c'est une blague !!!
Je vous avais promis que ce Master Class là serait consacré au Cold Reading.
C'est le premier d'ailleurs qui sera consacré au Cold Reading,
j'en referai sûrement un deuxième voire un troisième dans l'année
parce que là, y a matière à en parler.
On va dire que c'est l'introduction au Cold Reading.
Oui, mais le Cold Reading c'est quoi ?
Très bonne question Jamie ! Littéralement, en anglais, ça veut dire lecture à froid.
Le contraire c'est le Hot Reading. Il y a aussi le stock reading qui est autre chose, je vous en parlerai une prochaine fois.
Le Cold Reading, c'est le fait de voir une personne et de l'observer pour déduire des choses sur elle,
sur qui elle est, sur ce qu'elle pense, sur son état émotionnel,
sur son parcours social, sur ses attentes dans la vie :
ou elle va, d'où elle vient aussi, aussi pragmatique que ce soit, ou elle était juste avant d'être là.
C'est vraiment voir une personne dont on ne connait rien et essayer de déduire des choses.
Et c'est tellement passionnant à faire.
Le plus grand Cold Reader que vous connaissez, c'est Sherlock Holmes.
Alors qui est issu de l'imaginaire de Conan Doyle
mais qui lui a été inspiré par un professeur à lui qui était comme ça en fait,
qui observait et déduisait des choses et c'est comme ça qu'il a créé et inventé ce personnage.
C'est très intéressant parce que dans les ouvrages de Sherlock Holmes,
on apprend aussi tout une mécanique pour faire ça.
C'est pas réellement un manuel, mais c'est vraiment intéressant de les lire.
Donc le but du jeu dans le Cold Reading, c'est d'observer et de déduire.
Évidemment [bonjour à tous]
c'est terrible ça, à cause de Pierre Croce, dès qu'on dit "évidemment" , on pense à "bonjour à tous", je déteste !
Donc évidemment, le Cold Reading, ça demande une bonne culture générale.
Le mentalisme au global demande une bonne culture générale.
Ça veut pas dire qu'il faut apprendre des choses dans des encyclopédies tout le temps, j'ai jamais fait ça.
Soyez curieux de tout en permanence, demandez des détails.
Sachez savoir dire que vous ne savez pas
comme ça vous avez en permanence des explications qui viennent à vous.
Intéressez vous à tout et ça facilitera tout ce que vous allez faire dans le mentalisme.
Le plus compliqué dans le Cold Reading donc, je le disais tout à l'heure, c'est de s'entraîner.
Alors pour s'entrainer, y a des spots évidents dès le départ,
ce sont les lieux publics,
c'est le fait de se poser à une terrasse d'un café et d'observer un petit peu les gens,
ou aussi dans un parc ou dans les transports en commun, très bon ça aussi.
Alors qu'on soit bien clair, faites le discrètement !
Parce que quand vous allez commencer à vous poser pour regarder fixement une personne
pendant 10 minutes - 15 minutes - 20 minutes pour essayer de déduire des choses,
surtout dans les premières phases d'entrainement où on met beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de temps
on a tendance à se rapprocher et ...
On a l'air un peu chelou comme ça !
Le but n'étant pas de finir au commissariat
parce que là vous aurez tout le temps en fait de  ... de déduire votre compagnon de cellule
et vous allez pas aimer ce que vous allez déduire !
Soyez discret et entrer dans un processus d'observation
pour essayer de savoir et de comprendre un maximum de choses sur la personne.
Je vais vous donner ma propre méthodologie.
En premier j'essaie de déduire l'âge de la personne.
En déduisant son âge, je vais déjà connaître un petit peu ses attentes dans la vie.
Les attentes stéréotypées en fait.
Je pars quand même sur des constats de base et après j'affine.
Si la personne a 30 ans, je sais qu'elle est plus dans sa phase de réussite sociale.
Imaginez vous quelles peuvent être les priorités d'une personne à cet âge là.
Quelles peuvent être ses peurs, ses angoisses ? Dans quelle réalité elle vit ?
Ensuite, plutôt que de m'intéresser directement à la personne,
je m'intéresse tout de suite à tout ce qu'il y a autour
c'est-à-dire les objets, les accessoires qu'elle peut avoir.
Est ce qu'elle a un parapluie ? Si oui, il est comment?
Est ce qu'elle a un livre dans les mains ?
Est ce qu'elle a un journal dans les mains ? Dans ces cas là, c'est quel journal ?
Est ce qu'elle a des sacs de courses ? Si elle a des sacs de courses,
on jauge aussi assez rapidement si elle a fait des courses pour un, pour deux, si il y a des enfants dans le tas.
Si vous voyez son téléphone, vous allez voir la marque. Ça veut aussi dire pas mal de choses.
Vous pouvez aussi voir s'il est très abimé, pas trop abimé : ça aussi c'est significatif.
Essayez de voir tous les accessoires qu'il y a autour
avant de vous intéresser complètement à la personne en elle-même.
Ensuite, je regarde les extrémités de la personne.
Pas cette extrémité là, vous vous égarez !
Je commence par regarder les cheveux de la personne, ça en dit long.
Ça nous donne des détails sur le fait qu'elle ait eu le temps de se préparer ou pas le matin,
que ce soit un homme ou une femme, peu importe.
Ça permet aussi de voir à quel point la personne essaie de prendre soin d'elle et soin de son image
en fonction de la coupe de cheveux : est ce que c'est bien taillée, mal taillée ?
Ça permet aussi de voir si la personne prend soin d'elle ou pas en fonction,
ça marche pour les hommes ou pour les femmes d'ailleurs,
de la taille des racines si la personne a une couleur.
Selon mon coiffeur Hermès que vous avez vu dans une vidéo déjà au début de l'année,
que les cheveux poussent en moyenne d'un centimètre par mois.
Donc si voyez 3 cm de racines, ça veut dire que la personne,
ça fait 3 mois qu'elle a pas fait sa couleur.
Donc ça veut dire que soit elle est stressée, soit elle a pas le temps,
soit elle a des problèmes financiers peut-être.
En tout cas ça vous donne encore une information supplémentaire.
De la même manière je focalise assez rapidement sur les mains et sur les ongles.
Parce que les mains et les ongles disent beaucoup de choses sur une personne.
Déjà si la personne a des ongles jaunis, c'est une personne qui fume.
Si elle a une alliance ou s'il y a pas d'alliance ? S'il y a des bagues ?
S'il y a des bagues, de quelle qualité c'est ? S'il y a la montre ?
Est ce que ce sont des mains qui sont toutes lisses ?
Est ce que ce sont des mains de travailleur qui sont remplies d'ampoules ?
Tout comme les vêtements !
Est ce que les vêtements de la personne sont assortis ou pas ?
Est ce ça va bien ensemble ? Est ce que c'est réfléchi ?
Est ce que c'est fait avec goût ? Est ce que ça a été pris un petit peu au hasard dans l'armoire ?
Est ce que la personne est habillée de manière, on va dire un petit peu coquette ?
Ou alors est ce que c'est quelque chose qu'on l'oblige à porter, peut-être pour le travail ?
Si la personne, je vous prends un exemple concret là parce que j'ai eu le cas y a pas longtemps,
une personne qui était en costume, et on était le matin,
et vraiment la chemise était mal mise, mal rentrée.
Mais c'était pas grand chose. C'était juste assez pour savoir que la personne était partie à la bourre de chez elle.
Donc ça veut dire que la personne avait pas entendu son réveil.
Et vu les cernes qu'il y avait sous les yeux
et que les mains étaient encore un petit peu sales, surtout au niveau des ongles,
je pense que la personne avait fait la fête la veille et que le matin elle s'est réveillée.
Il a fallu enfiler le costume en speed et partir.
Je pense que l'étape douche même a été sautée, et la chemise était mal rentrée.
Enfin vous voyez, un tout petit détail peut en dire long sur ce qui s'est passé précédemment.
Ce que vous allez pouvoir voir, essayez de l'interpréter.
Essayer d'émettre des hypothèses. Elles seront souvent justes.
C'est pas extrêmement dur à faire le Cold Reading, c'est juste qu'on prend pas le temps d'observer
et on prend encore moins le temps d'essayer de faire des déductions.
Ce qui serait d'ailleurs formidable, c'est de pouvoir après aller discuter avec la personne
pour essayer de voir à quel point on avait raison ou pas en fait.
Est ce que 75% des hypothèses étaient bonnes ?
Est ce que 100% ou 0% ?
C'est compliqué je vous avoue si vous êtes dans un parc ou à une terrasse
d'observer quelqu'un 20 minutes, que la personne commence à flipper, d'aller la voir pour vérifier.
Mais c'est tout à fait faisable en soirée ou quand vous rencontrez quelqu'un que vous ne connaissez pas chez des amis.
Vous pouvez observer la personne tout un moment et après dans la soirée essayer de lui parler.
Il faut quand même que je termine le listing que moi je fais habituellement.
Il y a aussi les chaussures à regarder.
C'est très important les chaussures, ça en dira long
parce que au delà de la marque, de l'état, des lacets comment c'est fait etc ...
il y a aussi tout ce que vous allez pouvoir voir sur la chaussure et sous la chaussure peut vous intéresser,
surtout sur les chaussures des mecs !
Et dans les choses annexes mais qui, pour moi, font partie du Cold Reading
peut-être pas pour tout le monde mais moi je trouve que c'est vraiment important,
il y a déjà le fait de prendre conscience que la personne que vous observez
elle est à l'endroit ou vous êtes vous aussi, à cette heure-ci ce jour-ci.
Et ça aussi ça a un sens. Pourquoi elle est là ? Pourquoi elle est là et pas ailleurs ?
Essayez de répondre à ça, c'est intéressant.
En enfin vous pouvez chopper toutes les informations possibles et imaginables.
C'est-à-dire un bout de conversation, quelque chose de très significatif sur un tatouage,
un ticket de métro qui traine ...
Toutes les informations que vous pouvez prendre le plus rapidement possible, du regard, sont intéressantes.
Si vous vous entrainez à faire ça, vous allez vous améliorer.
A terme, ce qui est aussi cool à faire,
c'est de regarder une personne assez peu de temps,
de regarder ailleurs et d'essayer de faire les hypothèses sans la regarder
puis de la re-regarder pour voir si les hypothèses que vous émettiez de mémoire sont toujours bonnes de visu.
Voilà, je pense que cette première vidéo au niveau de tout ce processus d'entrainement là
et sur qu'est ce que le Cold Reading est suffisante pour commencer.
Prenez le temps déjà de faire ça et après on ira plus loin ensemble.
Je vais quand même vous recommander des bouquins pour ceux que ça intéresse.
C'est 3 bouquins que j'ai lus. J'ai essayé aussi de taper dans les moins chers.
Je vous mets tout dans les liens de toute manière.
Il y a l'édition complète de Sherlock Holmes qui est sortie en format numérique.
Vous pouvez le lire sur votre ordi ou sur les tablettes.
C'est sorti, j'ai vu ça y a pas très longtemps, pour 1.06 euros.
En format numérique donc si vous avez une tablette pour le lire ou si vous aimez bien lire sur l'ordi,
moi c'et pas toujours forcément mon cas, je vous mets le lien dedans.
Faites le, je pense que c'est la bible, pour le Cold Reading.
Au format papier, y a aussi un livre de poche qui regroupe les 4 grosses histoires de Sherlock Holmes.
Parce qu'en fait, Sherlock Holmes, y a 4 grosses histoires
et après c'est une quarantaine de nouvelles.
Et enfin un livre qui est parfait aussi pour commencer le Cold Reading et le parfaire,
alors y a pas le mot Cold Reading dessus,
c'est le livre de David Lieberman qui s'appelle "Lisez dans les pensées de votre interlocuteur" je crois.
Je vous mets aussi le lien dans le commentaire.
Voilà, j'espère que ça ça vous servira aussi parce qu'on m'a demandé de sourcer un peu les vidéos
ou au délà de sourcer en tout cas, d'essayer d'ouvrir pour ceux qui voulaient vraiment se documenter un peu plus.
Merci d'avoir regarder cette vidéo. C'est vous qui m'avez demander de parler du Cold Reading.
Donc j'espère que ça vous aura plu. Si c'est le cas, n'oubliez pas de laisser un petit ... allez y ...
Déduisez ce que j'attends là pour voir  ... Pas facile ou POUCE EN L'AIR !
Vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaîne si vous voulez ou regarder les anciens Master Class,
je vous mets une petite fiche ici.
Et n'oubliez pas que le Mental Vlog, c'est une vidéo par jour, tous les jours pendant un an depuis le 1er janvier.
Rendez-vous demain à 11h, parce que demain c'est dimanche, à 11h pour le prochain Mental Vlog. Ciao !